[Musique]
le nouveau produit est un nouveau
ministre de l'Éducation depuis la
démission fracassante jeudi de Dominique
Curly qui a quitté la grande table du
Conseil des ministres en accusant le
Premier ministre de s'approprier de plus
en plus de pouvoir
l'ex-ministre estime que Blade Higgs
prend des décisions importantes sans
consulter le Conseil des ministres il
caucus en plus de freiner tout effort de
réconciliation entre les communautés
linguistiques de la province je retrouve
Dominique Cardy dans nos studios de
Frédéric tenchakali j'en ai vu pas mal
des démissions dans ma carrière de
journaliste mais la vôtre était de loin
celle qui était la plus fracassante
pourquoi vous avez senti le besoin
d'écrire une lettre aussi pointue aussi
accusatrice
parce que les structures de nos
démocratie sont importantes et quand les
gouvernements qui nourrent ces
institutions ces structures ça ouvre la
porte pour extrémisme au papillisme de
gauche et à droite et c'est pour ça
qu'on voit partout dans le monde
aujourd'hui si on fait si on prend pas
nos restitutions démocratique comme
sérieuse on va les perdre et les membres
du gouvernement sont les gens qui sont
placés bien placés pour voir ces
événements et s'il y a le problème je
pense que c'est le responsabilités des
élus de dire la vérité dans la manière
la plus claire et fort que possible vous
dites dans la lettre que vous accusez
blinings de prendre des décisions sans
consulter des gens vous diraient que
c'est la prérogative du Premier ministre
de décider c'est lui le Premier ministre
dans le fond à quel point est-ce qu'il y
a une différence entre cette perception
là ce que vous avez vu parce que ce
n'est pas on n'a pas un système
présidentiel les premiers ministres ont
une
groupe exécutive le cabinet du
gouvernement qui sont là le choix du
Premier ministre et le seul demande et
que dans énormément de cas que tu as
besoin de consulter ces gens et en
particulier j'ai ciblé dans mon être un
exemple où on a le premier ministre a
éliminer une pleine niveau de notre
gouvernement des élus les gens qui sont
élus par la population en grand et avec
aucune consultation il a éliminé cette
ces institutions alors c'est quelque
chose qui est bizarre et de mon avis
dangereux et on a besoin encore de
soutenir nos systèmes sinon on va les
perdre jeudi avant de publier votre
lettre vous avez rencontré blining vous
lui avez fait part de ses préoccupations
là je présume que vous lui en aviez
parlé avant que vous étudiez
les décisions que c'était le temps pour
préparer pour mon départ deux semaines
passées maintenant un peu plus on va une
rencontre où le Premier ministre était
présenté avec un dossier de
d'information sur le système d'éducation
anglophone dans la province avec les
plans pour réforme qui était déjà
complétées les plans pour le futur et
avec toute cette information
en anglais
il faut pour un Premier ministre qui
était élu en Dior qu'il va éliminer la
politisation de gouvernement pour
assurer comprendre la décision basée sur
l'évidence pour moi c'était la fin de
route ce que vous avez vécu vous dans
l'éducation et vous l’impression que
d'autres collègues dans d'autres
portefeuilles au sein de votre
gouvernement qui vivent les mêmes
frustrations absolument c'est c'est
quelque chose que j'ai discuté avant mon
émission avec beaucoup de collègues et
encore après c'est un problème général
et c'est pour ça que j'ai plus de
décision que j'ai pris parce que un
point on a besoin de prendre de prendre
position et dire clairement que malgré
l'impact sur mon avenir sur mon futur
on a besoin de prendre des positions
basées sur les principes et pour
soutenir encore le système que on était
élu pour protéger il y avait pas
d'ouverture d'esprit de la part de
Monsieur X de changer les choses quand
vous lui en avez fait peur
non ça c'est le problème que il était
l'évidence qui était présenté en vendu
l'évidence des experts dans le système
des gens en or du système qui ont
présenté aussi et il a dit seulement
qu'il va vraiment cibler sur
l'élimination du Programme des Nations
françaises ici dans la preuve dans le
province pour pour les enfants
anglophones les étudiants anglophones
pour des raisons personnelles et
émotionnelles je pense il y avait une
obsession un peu avec le programme
financier français ça c'est c'est triste
mais en fait ça c'est aussi son
prérogative comme premier ministre
pousser les dossiers comme ça mais aussi
c'est responsabilité des membres du
cabinets de dire à un point que c'est
assez bon vous êtes il y avait un
problème émotionnel personnel entre
autres avec les programmes d'immersion
est-ce que Monsieur X a un problème avec
la difficulté avec ses liens entretenir
des liens avec la communauté francophone
au niveau c'est ça qui devient plus
obtenir inquiétant on avait deux
rapports sur les dossiers autour de
langues officielles l'année passée une
dirigée vers le ministère d'éducation et
on a promis tous les recommandations
dans quelques
semaines on avait un autre qui est
atterri sur le bureau du Premier
ministre sur les révisions sur les
droits des langues officielles et
entendre maintenant presque une an pour
voir la réponse et de réponse qui a été
assez claire que l'ancien chef du parti
un peu populiste ici qui a devenu
progressiste conservateur était nommé
non mais au cabinet alors se créer un
niveau d'inquiétude avec la communauté
francophone à la même niveau que
l'inquiétude que j'entends des
fonctionnaires dans le dans la fonction
publique alors deux grands groupes dans
la province qui sont inquiétés avec
l'action du gouvernement mais encore on
devrait discuter ces questions en public
nous sommes dans un démocratie quel est
le sud des choses pour vous dominicardie
et j'ai un peu plus de temps maintenant
je vais travailler un peu avec je suis
une membre du conseil pour un groupe qui
s'appelle canadien de centre glace on
essaie de créer un rassemblement pour
les politiques un peu plus centristes au
Canada en vue de division gauche toi
qu'on voit je vais avoir un peu plus de
temps pour aider à ce projet clairement
continuer de travailler comme une
députée pour mentir la description des
citoyens citoyens de rester
pour travailler pour créer les liens
entre les écoles Canadiens et les écoles
en Ukraine j'étais en Ukraine quelques
semaines passées et ça continue quelque
chose que je suis passionné de faire
tout complet pour soutenir l'Ukraine
avec leur
russe et je vais continuer ce travail
aussi bonne continuité alors Dominique
dis merci d'avoir été des autres merci
bien à bientôt